[Música]
pasamos ahora a los titulares de la
prensa con rosa pérez más de rosa
bienvenida muy buen día vamos a comenzar
con la portada del país brutalidad
policial en eeuu agentes arrastran
afuera su auto a un hombre negro
parapléjico rosa buenos días raúl exacto
vamos a empezar con este tema que
sucedió el 30 de septiembre pero que se
ha dado a conocer ahora porque
precisamente la persona que fue agredida
en este caso pues ha denunciado a la
policía de dayton ohio donde ocurrieron
los hechos por el registro e incautación
ilegal no lo que sucedió es que la
policía dice que vio salir a esta
persona clifford owens bike de una casa
donde supuestamente se venderían drogas
y cuando esta persona estaba ya en su
coche por la carretera pues fue parado
por la policía que le hacía salir del
coche él decía alegaba que era
parapléjico y que no podía salir tan
fácilmente del auto la policía le
repetía que que no salir no era una
opción y que si no colaboraba ella lo
iba a acabar arrastrando y es lo que
finalmente acaba sucediendo ahora a la
luz
la filmación de la cámara corporal de la
policía si te parece raúl vamos a ver
las imágenes porque hablan de por sí
solas aquí estamos viendo como pues la
policía está intentando sacar a un
insight del coche por la fuerza y les
repite que le van a hacer daño que es
parapléjico y bueno verás lo acaban
tirando al suelo él acaba pues
evidentemente se está quejando del dolor
de que le están haciendo daño está
pidiendo ayuda
y bueno pues estas imágenes como vemos
aquí la fecha lo que comentábamos ahora
pues han salido a la luz gracias a la
denuncia de este ciudadano
afroestadounidense y precisamente pues
queríamos no comentar exportada y la
destaca hoy el país también hoy 12 de
octubre que se señala pues el inicio de
la colonización de américa que como
bueno señalan muchísimos analistas el
legado que llega hasta nuestros días
pues es entre otras cosas este racismo
sistémico que implica pues también entre
otras cosas cómo se puso sobre la mesa
más que nunca a raíz del asesinato de
georges floyd que las personas
realizadas sobre todo afro
estadounidenses y latinas pues en
estados unidos y alrededor del mundo son
las primeras víctimas de los abusos
policiales no impresionante además como
lo hablan por el pelo y lo tiran al piso
rosa sigamos con ese tema de hoy 12 de
octubre vamos ahora a pasar al universal
de méxico dice la editorial indígenas
entre lucha y resistencia
buenos días raúl exactamente este
editorial de el universal de méxico lo
que destaca es que precisamente hoy 12
de octubre pues que en parte también se
va a reivindicar y se va a señalar pues
la importancia cultural y de identidad
de todos los pueblos indígenas
originarios de aquí de américa latina
donde recuerda este editorial hay 54
millones de habitantes pertenecientes a
los pueblos indígenas pero que dice
lamentablemente desde chile hasta méxico
a menudo pertenecer a un pueblo indígena
un pueblo indígena
significa pobreza discriminación y
olvido por parte de las instituciones y
dice muy bien hay que américa latina
tiene que reconocerse como un territorio
multicultural pero también tiene que
haber una igualdad de derechos de acceso
a los derechos básicos por parte de
todos los ciudadanos
rosa vamos ahora con 12 caricaturas de
este día empezamos con el universo de
ecuador dice descubriendo américa eso es
raúl vamos a ver qué está exacto esta
caricatura no que destaca hoy de bonnie
el este ilustrador
pues equipara el momento en que llegan
los colonizadores américa en 1492 y son
saludados no pues por los indígenas pues
con la actualidad no con 2001 donde
vemos en la frontera estadounidense como
pues los agentes de la fuerza pública
están echando a las personas migrantes
una imagen que nos habla muchísimo hoy
en día después de todas las imágenes de
brutalidad policial no que que vimos
pues hace unas semanas incluso con
agentes de la policía montados a caballo
persiguiendo a personas indígenas no y
como los han señalado tantos analistas
aquí en france24 pues como la política
exterior de eeuu tiene muchas
implicaciones en la desestabilización de
la región la historia se repite rosa no
vamos ahora con otra caricatura el
diario punto es los conquistadores aquí
creo que tenemos que ser un poquito de
teatro rosa bueno si te parece porque
está esta caricaturas y que tiene letra
digamos vamos a ponerle voz para que
nuestra audiencia pues pueda captar bien
el mensaje aquí vemos a santiago abascal
recordemos el líder del partido de
extrema derecha box hablando en un bar
con pablo casado el líder del partido
popular de la derecha tradicional
española y pues santiago abascal de la
extrema derecha dice no hubo abuso a ver
somos hombres conquistadores y cuando
vas de conquista y se te insinúan
vestidas que les ves todas las riquezas
todo el poderío pues dices mío es y
ellas saben que esto va así seguro les
gustó te lo digo yo pues básicamente no
lo que está haciendo pues el ilustrador
en este caso es equiparar esta retórica
de la conquista con esta retórica de la
violación no y es que precisamente pues
se trata de la extrema derecha y de la
derecha española que reivindican con
todo orgullo sin ningún tipo de
cuestionamiento de la colonización con
todas las violencias que supuso y como
sabemos no el cuerpo de la mujer ha sido
en muchas ocasiones territorio de
conquista y esto es lo que está
criticando aquí manuel ávila este
ilustre pues rosa gracias por esos
titulares de la prensa del día de hoy
nos vemos mañana con más vamos ahora con
nuestro primer invitado del día sobre
todo de ese tema que estamos hablando
que usted
[Música]